una anhelada luz se encendió para los
refugiados en el tigre en medio de los
enfrentamientos que los habían dejado
sin asistencia humanitaria con la firma
de un acuerdo entre el gobierno de
etiopía y la onu las organizaciones
sociales que trabajan en esta región
podrán volver al terreno un día antes de
que se produjera la firma del acuerdo el
portavoz del alto comisionado de la onu
para los refugiados ya había alertado
sobre las repercusiones del bloqueo a la
asistencia de esta cerca de 96 mil
personas que en su mayoría llegaron allí
huyendo de la violencia y el mal los
campamentos se quedarán sin alimentos lo
que hará que el hambre y la desnutrición
sean un peligro real una advertencia que
venimos emitiendo desde que comenzó el
conflicto hace casi un mes
también estamos alarmados por los
informes no confirmados de ataques
secuestros y reclutamiento forzoso en
los campos de refugiados
desde hace más de cuatro semanas el
ingreso de los trabajadores sociales
permanecía prohibido en esta región en
guerra en la que habitan más de 5
millones de personas lo que equivale al
5 por ciento de la población de etiopía
a pesar de que el conflicto inició el 4
de noviembre las tensiones en el tigre
venían incrementándose desde hacía
varios meses y su estallido ensombreció
el panorama de los refugiados quienes
quedaron prácticamente aislados y a
merced de las ofensivas según cálculos
de la onu sólo en los últimos días más
de 5000 refugiados huyeron al este de
sudán se espera que con la entrada en
vigor del acuerdo no sólo esta población
vulnerable recupere el acceso a ayudas
alimentarias y médicas sino también que
se adelante una misión de apoyo en la
vecina región de afar